bon choix bernard tapie a droit à
nouveau à la une de tous les journaux
même les plus sérieux le député des
bouches du rhône sens serait sans doute
bien passé
bernard tapie a a été en effet réveillé
à l'aube peu après 6h du matin par les
policiers de la brigade financière de
paris réveil mouvementé
bernard tapie a protesté rudement mais
n'étant plus protégé par son immunité
parlementaire a été conduit dans le
bureau du juge d'instruction qui enquête
sur la gestion du phocéa le yacht de
l'homme d'affaires
eva joly l'a mis en examen pour abus de
biens sociaux l'a placé sous contrôle
judiciaire pu la laisser repartir cette
interpellation alimenté toutes les
conversations de la classe politique
nous allons y revenir
mais écoutons d'abord avec maryse burgot
et christophe portera le récit de cette
folle journée qui a commencé à l'heure
du laitier 6h ce matin branle bas de
combat au 52 rue des saints-pères à
paris huit policiers tambourine à la
porte du domicile de bernard tapie c'est
la concierge qui ouvre robe de chambre
quelques minutes plus tard bernard tapie
est interpellé insultes mouvement
d'humeur
le député sera finalement menotté par
les policiers des policiers qui depuis
deux jours étaient en planque dans cet
hôtel juste en face de la maison de
bernard tapie
un dispositif discret exigé par le juge
d'instruction eva joly en fait madame
doc avait effectivement des policiers
dans votre hôtel pendant deux jours là
vous saviez que c'était des courses 1
6h30
les inspecteurs conduisent bernard tapie
à la brigade financière dans le xiiie
arrondissement de paris
les policiers notice you députés le
mandat d'amener délivré par le juge joly
il dresse également l'homme d'affaires
un procès verbal pour outrage à agent
pendant ce temps au 52 rue des saints
pères des fils les proches de bernard
tapie tous se disent choqués par la
méthode utilisée
quand même incroyable passion se
trouvait kiejman ans qui soit l'âge vers
6 heures du matin elle pouvait
parfaitement lui signifier que la
vocation est à présent il s'est toujours
rendu aux convocations
comment expliquez vous son ajustement
des foyers au top en donnant ce matin
pourquoi bas pour faire un pli pauvres
car comme d'habitude en sort encore rien
faire de simples rapides sa chute vers
l'armé du folklore il y en aura aussi
lorsque bernard tapie et conduits au
palais de justice peu après 9h30
la première sortie de véhicules sirènes
hurlantes n'est en fait qu'un leurre
bernard tapie n'est pas dans ses
voitures
le député et dans ce fourgon à l'abri
des regards
peu avant 10 heures il arrive au palais
de justice
il est immédiatement amené dans le
bureau du juge d'instruction
l'entretien va durer deux heures 11h15
sortie souriante du conseil des
ministres et si les micros se tendent
c'est évidemment pour recueillir les
réactions à l'interpellation de bernard
tapie au sol sol immunité parlementaire
avec tpv juges décider au siège de
bernard tapie finance
la présidente par le l d'acharnement
judiciaire crois qu'on peut pas pousser
les gens jusqu'à l'extrémité je crois
qu'actuellement on est en train de
pousser ça fait un an je vous dis qu'on
est danseur dans un trouble dans un
brouhaha qui fait que chaque jour on se
dit mais qu'est ce qui va encore nous
arriver
ce qui arrive dans le bureau du juge
d'instruction peu avant midi c'est la
mise en examen de bernard tapie pour
abus de biens sociaux et fraude fiscale
il est placé sous contrôle judiciaire
après cette matinée mouvementée c'est un
homme libre qui regagne discrètement son
domicile de la rue des saints-pères
bernard tapie rentrer chez lui
il est midi le tout paris on a beaucoup
parlé le tout marseille et secouer
patrice veulent et jean françois georges
et y sont allés du côté du fief
électoral de bernard tapie la belle de
mai on est moins bien sûr et du côté de
l'om attristé
s'agit il d'un calot convoqué
normalement il n'allait pas partir il
est allé à beaucoup de convocation non
au jjb fille tous alors c'est ça la
politique est un magouilleur cette plaie
des avis divergents cet après midi à la
belle de mai le fief électoral de
bernard tapie à proximité de sa
permanence les commentaires allaient bon
train
beaucoup parlé d'acharnement mais ça ne
m'étonne pas on se pense il affiche
ainsi rien politiquement parlant je suis
pas du même bord que vous mais je pense
qu'il a fait pour l'ol et l'om c'est
marseille l'om la passion marseillaise
cet après midi le club entamé sa
reconquête objectif division 1 et le nom
du président était sur toutes les lèvres
quand on va chercher quelqu'un 6 heures
du matin et que l'on relâche deux heures
après bon il ya un problème on n'a pas
besoin d'eux
d'aller rechercher à cette heure là
c'est malheureux c'est triste pour
l'homme parce que moi j'estime beaucoup
bernard et je pense que il va s'en
sortir
j'en ai tout coeur avec lui on le prête
depuis un an comme une cible vivante il
ya un acharnement dans dans les méthodes
qui est tout à fait déplaisant et qui
révoltent souvent l'opinion publique et
quelquefois des responsables aussi pour
les supporters c'est devenu une question
d'habitude cette saison commence comme
la précédente dans la tempête judiciaire
moi je dis qu'ils en font un plat parce
que depuis huit ans qu'il prison mais au
delà des impressions tous attendent ici
une décision de justice pour en savoir
un peu plus n'oublions pas le fond de la
sphère qui a abouti à cette mise en
examen le juge d'instruction eva joly
reproche à bernard tapie des
irrégularités dans la gestion de son
yacht le phocéa valérie gage et
saint-malo en juillet 88 bernard tapie
et c'était comme un héros à bord de son
voilier le phocéa il vient de battre le
record de la traversée de l'atlantique
le quatre mâts qui l'a acheté en 82 à la
veuve du navigateur alain colas fait
alors sa fierté depuis l'horizon s'est
quelque peu obscurci car le phocéa est à
l'origine des ennuis actuels de bernard
tapie
les deux informations judiciaires
confiées au juge joly porte l'une et
l'autre sur le voilier premiers dossiers
la gestion du phocéa par la société
alain colas tahiti filiale du groupe
bernard tapie
plusieurs perquisitions auraient révélé
des transfert de fonds suspects entre
les deux sociétés
selon les enquêteurs la société
gestionnaire du phocéa aurait largement
sous facturer l'utilisation d'une à dire
par bernard tapie
la deuxième information judiciaire fait
elle suite à une plainte du fisc le
phocéa est enregistré comme navires
marchands alors que selon
l'administration il s'agit d'un bateau
de plaisance le fisc a estimé son
préjudice à près de 12 millions et demi
de francs c'est sur la base de ces deux
dossiers que bernard tapie a ce matin
été mise en examen pour abus de biens
sociaux et pour fraude fiscale
et la question qui s'est posée toute la
journée s'impose ce soir dominique
verdeilhan pourquoi 6h du matin et bien
parce qu'il fallait mener de front une
course contre la montre est une chasse à
l'homme il y avait pour le juge lit une
date butoir le 19 juillet prochain
ce jour là bernard tapie sera protégé
par une nouvelle immunité parlementaire
européenne cette fois chasse à l'homme
car tapie est précédé d'une réputation
celle de ne pas être très coopératif
avec la justice au lendemain de la
commission à l'assemblée nationale la
semaine dernière qui s'était déclaré
favorable à la levée de l'immunité
parlementaire
le juge joly avait pris une première
précaution celle de mettre sur écoute
téléphonique
le député des écoutes qui vont lui
confirmé ses craintes bernard tapie
pourrait prendre le large pour ne pas
répondre du dossier fossé à son voilier
qui est lui condamné à rester à quai
crainte confirmée ce soir par le garde
des sceaux lui même qui annonce que
bernard tapie comptait organiser une
mission humanitaire au rwanda le juge
joly ensuite passé à ce moment là à une
deuxième phase
la planque depuis trois jours de
policiers devant l'hôtel particulier de
bernard tapie
cette nuit après le vote des députés le
juge lee a obtenu le feu vert de sa
hiérarchie
ce fut le mandat d'amener spectaculaire
efficace
un épisode à grand spectacle pour le
feuilleton de l'été après celui l'an
dernier de l'om vers alors nous l'avons
dit bernard tapie a été placé sous
contrôle judiciaire dominée que
concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut dire
alors quand ce matin nous avons vu
bernard tapie sortir du bureau du juge
il était pâle tendu le visage chiffonné
mais souriant parce que libre de mandat
de dépôt il n'en fut pas question
seulement d'un contrôle judiciaire
interdiction de quitter le territoire
jusqu'au 18 juillet remise au juge de
ses papiers d'identité pas de caution
l'a sans doute estimé que bernard tapie
avait à cette problèmes financiers
interdiction aussi de rencontrer les
protagonistes du dossier tapie est
convoqué dans le bureau du juge joly le
18 juillet prochain le lendemain il
pourra aller à bruxelles pour siéger
comme député européen
merci dominique si bernard tapie a pu
être interpellés de la sorte parce
qu'une majorité écrasante de députés a
levé hier son immunité parlementaire la
classe politique très attentive au
feuilleton tapie ne pouvait donc rester
indifférente à ce nouvel épisode elle ne
l'a pas été reportage de véronique
sainte
vais-je en corner tout l'après midi la
rumeur à rouler si bernard tapie avait
été interpellé à l'aube avec un tel
déploiement de force c'est parce que des
écoutes téléphoniques auraient révélé
qu'il s'apprêtait à quitter la france
pour aller au rwanda dans le cadre d'une
opération humanitaire
beaucoup croyaient au gag mais
finalement le garde des sceaux lui même
confirmé à demi mots je dis je est
suffisamment d'éléments pour le crains
qu'au même moment dans les couloirs la
température montait et les députés
s'échauffaient 60000 personnes qui sont
mis en garde à vue dans ce pays chaque
année
trois cent soixante mille monsieur tapie
est un français comme les autres
une mise en scène quelque peu théâtral
ans si on l'avait voulu tourner un
remake de règlements de comptes à ok
corral ou de quelques instants que ce
soit n'auraient pas le procédé
c'était à mon avis dutil je suis
profondément choquée je ne suis pas
étonné je suis choqué y en a assez de
ces justice en public que cette justice
en vitrine
ce qui est choquant c'est qu'un député
puisse se trouver dans cette situation
lors bernard tapie a été victime d'un
acharnement ou au contraire en tire t'il
partie et puis y'a t'il acharnement ou
au contraire procédure normale le
premier ministre s'est bien gardée
d'intervenir mais le débat n'a pas fini
d'alimenter les conversations et le
feuilleton continue
bernard tapie confronté hier à la levée
de son immunité parlementaire avait mis
en garde ses collègues contre les
conséquences politiques d'une telle
décision le juge d'instruction doit
donner indirectement raison ce matin en
procédant à son interpellation
désormais relais de chavaux plus
personne n'est à l'abri vous savez qu'un
homme politique soit traité comme un
citoyen ordinaire et doivent répondre de
ses actes au fond c'est plutôt
réconfortant regard du fonctionnement de
la démocratie en revanche qu'un député
mis en cause dans une affaire financière
privée soit traité comme un truand
inscrits au fichier du grand banditisme
c'est à dire mis sur écoute surveillés
par des policiers en planque devant chez
lui depuis 36 heures interpellé à l'aube
puis remis en liberté quelques heures
plus tard cela paraît évidemment
beaucoup plus étonnant l'opération
volontairement spectaculaire
correspondrait au personnage hors norme
qu'est bernard tapie le juge joly comme
le procureur eric de montgolfier ne
serait-elle pas tu
tombé dans le piège de la médiatisation
à outrance pratiqué par bernard tapie
politiquement en tout cas l'opération
n'est sans doute pas mauvaise pour le
député des bouches du rhône qui joue
désormais sur le registre du martyr
victime de l'acharnement de tous le
nouveau robin des bois
porte-drapeau de ceux qui veulent
bousculer le système les affaires
répéter la pression judiciaire en tout
cas n'avait pas empêché bernard tapie
d'obtenir 12 % l'élection européenne
enfin aujourd'hui le juge a sans doute
créé un précédent car un traitement
aussi sévère ne serait être réservée aux
seuls bernard tapie mais devrait être
appliquée à tous les hommes politiques
qu'ils soient de l'opposition ou de la
majorité
impliqué dans des affaires privées ou
publiques alors faut-il encore le dire
la justice se doit d'être toujours
serein rapide égale pour tous
ce rebondissement matinale a été si
spectaculaire qui a été évoqué à nouveau
tout à l'heure au cours de la réception
organisée par le président de
l'assemblée nationale à l'hôtel de
lassay
philippe séguin a tenu à cette occasion
à inviter le chef de l'état qui a
accepté et qui a renoué avec une
tradition abandonnée depuis près de 20
ans françois mitterrand n'a peut-être
compliqué pour commenter les dernières
côtes du bv à paris match elle reste
stable pour lui 47% d'opinions
favorables contre 45% d'opinions
défavorables légère baisse en revanche
pour edouard balladur cinquante deux
pour cent d'opinions favorables toute la
rédaction de france 2 a été ému par la
nouvelle qui nous est parvenu cet
après-midi d'alger nos envoyés spéciaux
véronique taveau christian hottin
christophe noyon et philippe frémont
couvrait la manifestation du mouvement
pour la république quand un attentat
s'est produit
trois des membres de l'équipe ont été
légèrement blessés ils ont effectué
cependant leur travail avant de
retrouver en direct d'alger véronique
taveau et christian hottin regardant
leurs reportages
tout avait pourtant bien commencé
presque dans un climat de fête
des milliers de personnes avaient
répondu présent à l'appel du mpr le
mouvement pour la république
une marche pour commémorer le deuxième
anniversaire de la mort de mohamed
boudiaf le président algérien facile aux
cris de algérie libre et démocratique
des femmes des hommes ont défilé dans
les rues d'alger
du côté des forces de l'ordre tous
devaient aussi être en place tireurs
d'élite tout le long du parcours et dans
les rues des centaines de ninja les
forces spéciales vous devez parfaitement
se passer
et puis tout à coup tout a basculé au
passage du président du mouvement pour
la république saïd saadi deux grenades
ont été lancées suivie immédiatement de
tirs à l'armé automatique
panique indescriptible sur le sol des
dizaines de blessés et sans doute
plusieurs morts mais ce soir impossible
d'en connaître le nombre exact
les blessés les plus graves vont être
soignés sur le trottoir les autres
évacués dans les hôpitaux les plus
proches
blessé aux jambes notre moteur physique
frémont il a été immédiatement
transporté à l'hôpital mustapha colère a
dit nation crie mais surtout
incompréhension cette marche se voulait
démocratique
elle a viré au cauchemar ce soir alger
est sous très haute surveillance
les forces de l'ordre se sont déployés
un peu partout dans la ville on vient de
voir vos images véronique les images de
christian hottin de philippe et de
christophe moyon
comment allez vous j'ai envie de vous
demander d'abord ça simplement écouter
ça va ça aurait pu être pire sans doute
je voudrais surtout rassurer tout de
suite la famille de philippe rémond
parce qu'on a vu les images en voyant ça
on a l'impression qu'il est très
gravement blessé en fait il est blessé
aux jambes il va passer la nuit à
l'hôpital mais il sera rapatrié demain
sans problème je veux surtout que sa
famille ne se sent goy spaans fasse pas
trop de soucis contout reste de l'équipe
christophe noyon et à l'ambassade
actuellement de france qui nous
accueillent ce soir il est blessé
également à la jambe quant à moi j'ai un
petit éclat dans la dans la jambe qui va
être enlevé ce soir par le chirurgien
l'ambassade de france et vous êtes là ce
soir avec non direct avec à vos côtés
christian hottin christian qui portait
la caméra on arrive aux images vous avez
travaillé christian malgré le choc
malgré la secousse alors que s'est-il
passé vous étiez au milieu des
manifestants en fait j'étais en train de
me filmer le président saadi au moment
où effectivement ça a commencé il ya eu
2 deux explosions
et tout d'un coup donc la foule a
commencé à courir et après ces
explosions il ya eu quelques tirs qu'on
a pu entendre et donc effectivement
souvent j'ai commencé j'ai continué à
tourner voilà et puis il ya eu après
beaucoup de beaucoup faire c'est une
panique indescriptible
c'était quand même très très éprouvant
mais bon dans ces cas-là on réfléchit
pas toujours à ce qui se passe vraiment
content
né à tourner quoi parce qu'on est là
pour ça on n'a pas envie je n'ai pas
envie ce soir me poser trop de questions
parce que vous êtes un petit peu
j'imagine fatigué simplement véronique à
votre avis qui était visé par cet
attentat
je pense que c'est clairement saïd sadi
qui était visée parce que ça s'est
produit en fin l'attentât s'est produit
exactement moment lui arrivait alors on
ne sait pas encore exactement s'il
s'agit de grenade ou bien si ce sont
deux bombes qui ont été télécommandée
il ya eu ensuite donc les rafales
mais c'est clair je pense que c'est lui
qui était visé par l'attentât
ça veut dire qu'il devient très
dangereux à alger de manifester pour la
démocratie
absolument ça devient de plus en plus
dangereux est-ce que ce qui est fou dans
cette histoire quand même c'est que
cette marche était une marche
démocratique organisé pour les citoyens
par les citoyens et quelques elles
correspondent exactement à l'eau
deuxième anniversaire de la mort du
président boudiaf donc symboliquement
c'est important que cette attente a eu
lieu aujourd'hui c'est un signe c'est un
symbole alors on s'attaque aujourd'hui
encore aux symboles de la démocratie de
la liberté de la liberté d'expression et
c'est terrible ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en algérie
merci véronique merci christian au nom
de toute la rédaction me prie de vous
embrasser ce soir et de vous souhaiter à
philips qui est à l'hôpital un très
prompt rétablissement revenez vite merci
larbi beddiaf qui appartient au fils en
france vient d'apprendre avec a été
interpellé qui avaient été interpellés
lors du coup de filet de novembre
dernier a été arrêté de nouveau hier ils
étaient en possession de munitions de
guerre et de faux papiers algériens il
est interpellé par la brigade de
recherche de la gendarmerie des
hauts-de-seine
branle bas de combat à gaza et à jéricho
mais la formule cette fois n'est plus
approprié ne s'agit plus de combats mais
de paix yasser arafat à l'intention de
se rendre dans ces territoires désormais
autonome dès vendredi charles enderlin
le premier surpris ses titres ravine le
chef du gouvernement israélien
oui dit il nabil chaath a annoncé la
venue d'arafat
mais il n'y aura pas de visites
sans coordination avec nous lorsque nous
aurons décidé nous vous le dirons
et ce soir le cabinet rabin a donné une
réponse positive
en principe donc le chef de l'olp et
empruntera pour entrer à gaza le même
trajet que les policiers palestiniens
le terminal de rafah à la frontière
égyptienne c'est là que des problèmes
risquent de voir le jour
en effet aux termes des accords les
israéliens doivent approuver chaque
passage il n'est pas sûr qu'ils auront
le temps d'examiner les dossiers de
toute la suite d'arafat à gaza même les
habitants a accueilli la nouvelle de
l'arrivée du chef de l'olp et avec
d'autant plus d'enthousiasmé que 400
prisonniers palestiniens ont été libérés
par israël
aujourd'hui la réaction de la droite
israélienne et du mouvement des
implantations est diamétralement opposée
c'est ultra promettent de grandes
manifestations de masse contre la venue
d'arafat
ils veulent notamment bloqué toutes les
voies d'accès à jéricho où ils
pourraient se rendre dimanche ou lundi
et jéricho se prépare depuis fort
longtemps à l'arrivée du chef historique
des palestiniens didier epelbaum toutes
les bonnes places sont prises depuis des
semaines autour de la place centrale de
jéricho des grandes chaînes de télé se
sont arrachés des terrasses à 20000 ou
50 mille francs
ça fait des mois que jerry corps évêques
d'un discours historique yasser arafat
prononcerait sur le balcon de la mairie
maintenant ça approche et jéricho se
fait belle avec application mais sans
fébrilité dans les territoires autonomes
la paix est déjà plus qu'un rêve entre
avril et juin selon l'armée israélienne
le nombre des actes de violence dans la
région de gaza a baissé de 80% en
cisjordanie 40%
mais pour que cette demie paix fragile
tienne il faudra encore beaucoup de
progrès
il est temps qu arafat viennent pour
appliquer de nouvelles idées pour cette
communauté
parce qu'elle attend depuis des années
cette occasion en or peu opérations
discrètes et détendue sous l'oeil d'un
policier palestiniens des israéliens aux
un câble de fibre optique
mais ils nous ont offert du café des
gâteaux et sont vraiment très sympa un
nouveau commerce florissant la jéricho
connection location de services pour
journalistes sans domicile fixe c'est à
peu près 1000 dollars par mois
il y a trois pièces avec le toit mais
pas de vue directe sur la place enfin
c'est tout près c'est le principal
en attendant l'invasion des journalistes
des palestiniens et des israéliens
branches d'une centaine de lignes de
téléphone ambiance débonnaire la police
palestinienne surveille surtout la coupe
du monde la modeste télé palestinienne
rêve à sa première émission la
retransmission prochaine de l'arrivée
d'arafat au bout du couloir de la télé
un mirage depuis des mois jericho rêve
qu'un roi mage s'installera ici dans
cette villa avec toute la patience que
peut avoir une ville dont les murs les
plus anciens ont dix mille ans françois
léotard a pu constater sur place
l'efficacité de l'opération turquoise le
ministre de la défense était aujourd'hui
au milieu des soldats français qui
remplissent la mission qui leur a été
confiée humanitaire mais qui reste
vigilant reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux benoît duquesne et joseph tual
première étape de la tournée de françois
léotard en territoire rwandais le camp
de nyarushishi le seul et unique quand
placé sous la protection d'une
cinquantaine de soldats français
la seule démonstration tangible de
l'aspect humanitaire de l'opération
turquoise
huit mille réfugiés ont été rassemblés
ici par les gendarmes rwandais est pris
en charge par la croix rouge
mais la présence de soldats français à
sécuriser des tutsis qui se trouvent ici
est mis fin aux règlements de comptes de
la milice
vous voyez tous ces milliers de gens qui
sont autour de nous
c'est eux qui sont protégés aujourd'hui
par défense française si nous étions pas
là probablement serait-il très menacé
c'est déjà assez un résultat et en plus
nous sommes pas tout seul là chaque fois
on se tourne vers la france ça nous
touche pas tout seul pourquoi serions
nous les seuls à devoir en permanence à
intervenir partout dans le monde
nous l'avons fait nous le faisons avec
le maximum de coeur de générosité et
efficacité comme nous le pouvons nous ne
sommes pas seuls notre vocation c'est de
partir vous bien que ça soit clair notre
vocation c'est de laisser la place des
organisations humanitaires
et si possible des africains parce que
c'est une crise africaine qui doit être
au maximum géré par les africains en
attendant la france est seule ou presque
avec pour l'instant 300 militaires
déployés au rwanda et même si à terme
ils seront mille de ce côté-ci de la
frontière c'est peu face aux centaines
de milliers de réfugiés
face aux exactions qui continue et face
au fpr qui progressent les infiltrations
jusqu'à trois kilomètres des premières
positions françaises mais les ordres
sont claires les soldats ne doit pas
rechercher le contact
la mission turquoise n'en est qu'à ses
débuts et l'on s'interroge déjà sur ses
limites certes les français ne veulent
rester que deux mois mais ce délai
suffira-t-il aux forces de l'onu pour se
déployer certes ils ne veulent pas
intervenir dans ce conflit mais les
populations locales et les politiques
qui les ont accueillis comme des
sauveurs comprennent de moins en moins
cette neutralité
bref les choses ne font que commencer et
de l'aveu même de françois léotard
les difficultés sont à venir la france
pour l'instant a mangé son pain blanc
en france le smic et les allocations
chômage augmenteront de 2,1 pour cent à
partir du 1er juillet prochain les
syndications mécontents mais le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu aller au-delà
forget a été éliminé en quarts de finale
à wimbledon par ivanisevic mais cette
défaite ne compromet bien les nombreuses
familles les problèmes du français sur
le circuit comme disent nos amis
sportifs et c'est la dernière image de
ce journal qui est terminée sophie
davant dans un instant vous annoncera le
retour du beau temps partout en france
ensuite à 21h10 un téléfilm de jean
louis bertucelli dit maman tu m'aimes
à 22h45 les amants du siècle frédéric
mitterrand 23h50 le dernier journal vous
sera présentée par philippe lefait
demain matin à 7h50
gérard leclerc recevra julien dray le
député socialiste de l'essonne il vous
parlera sans aucun doute de bernard
tapie qui a été interpellé très tôt ce
matin par
les policiers de la brigade financière
de paris mais qui a été libéré ensuite
si j'ose dire par le juge d'instruction
aux alentours de midi bonne soirée sur
france 2 demain 13h daniel bilalian je
vous retrouve à 21 bonsoir